[Music]
foreign
much like zombies the infected from The
Last of Us can be killed by a headshot
but it isn't as easy as one might think
since they are faster and nimbler than
normal zombie Walkers and somewhat like
Joe's from the World War Z movie in
agility and ferocity so here in this
video we will showcase the various ways
the different forms of the infected from
the laws of us can be defeated and
killed so let's get into it
firstly the runners in The Last of Us
Runners are considered to be one of the
weaker types of infected they are fast
and agile but they lack the durability
and strength of the other infected forms
such as the clickers they are humans who
transform within two days of coming into
touch with the goddess of brain
infection they are distinguished by
their high speed lethargic assaults and
proclivity to crowd their prey like
swarming
Runners are often encountered in groups
and can quickly overwhelm a person if
they're not careful however they are
also easier to take out than other
infected forms and a few well-placed
shots are a well-timed strike from a
melee weapon can quickly take them down
shooting a runner in the legs will slow
them down and make them easier to take
out you can also finish them with a
melee weapon or a few shots from a
firearm directly in the head or one can
place traps to incapacitate their
movements and if nothing else works or
you're feeling cold a monitor of
cocktail will burn them to death
the second one stalkers this is the
second stage of the infection which can
take anywhere from two weeks to a whole
year to develop stalkers have the speed
and eyesight of Runners and the ferocity
of clickers the stalker's most
noticeable features their croaking noise
which is followed by the appearance of
fungal growths on the victim's head and
face leaving the hose with just one eye
and a development of a Proto
echolocation ability
stalkers are relatively weak and can be
taken out with a few well-placed shots
or a well-timed strike from a melee
weapon they are also slower and less
agile than Runners making them an easier
Target it's most important to be aware
of one surrounding when facing stalkers
as they can appear unexpectedly an
attack from any direction so laying
traps for them isn't as easy as you
might think unless you're a pro or a
chess master overall stalkers are a step
up in difficulty from Runners but still
relatively easier to kill in melee
combat or if they have been seen they
can be easily taken out by Firearms they
also share the same vulnerability to
fire
thirdly the clickers these are the
famous iconic third stage forms which
have been exposed to fungus for over a
year and now have the strength far
beyond that of a person a normal man the
fungus that has developed from their
diseased brains has completely robbed
and ruined their looks somewhat leaving
them with just a mouth and sharp teeth
they are also one of the most dangerous
forms of the infected as their entire
body is nearly indestructible to
Conventional Weaponry since the fungus
grows like an armor plating around them
they also move and are Guided by
echolocation
a shot to the head is the only way to
kill a clicker quickly and effectively
headshots will immediately incapacitate
a clicker making it the most reliable
way to take them out blunt force trauma
from a melee weapon like a hammer a bat
or anything can be used to kill a
clicker but it requires getting up close
to the enemy and since they use sonar or
echolocation to walk around stalking one
or ambushing them isn't really a good
idea since they would hear the slightest
sound made by humans while fire can be
used to take out other types of infected
it is not effective against clickers who
are nearly indestructible to all forms
of attack except for a shot to the Head
number four the bloaters bloaters are
the fourth rarest and the most lethal
stage of the infected after years and
years of exposure they develop and reach
this stage they are very powerful and
physically threatening and they are
covered in thick fungus that serves as
armor plating as a result their skin
produces massive patches of scale-like
tissue that glow in the dark generating
mycotoxin pouches that wrap around the
entire body and are capable of being
thrown or exploding harming or killing
anyone in the vicinity
a shot to the head can kill a bloater
but it's much less effective than other
ways we will discuss here blooders have
a thick spore-filled body that makes
them highly resistant to damage so a
headshot is not always a guaranteed kill
blotters can release a cloud of toxic
spose that can be deadly to a person in
close proximity so getting close to them
is almost always fatal blooders can
however be reliably killed with
explosive weapons such as grenades or
mulch of cocktails it's also the most
effective way to take them out but it
requires getting close to them so it
could be a suicide run
the fifth one the shamblers the
shamblers are a different fourth stage
form an alternate version that is
assumed to have originated or formed as
a result of exposure to enormous amounts
of water or humidity as opposed to the
regular dry environments in which
bloaters thrive in shamblers are
Abominations that expel gaseous acid
upon contact with the victim they walk
slowly at first but if they hear
anything they can run and when
threatened they spontaneously expel
corrosive spores around their body
unlike bloaters though shamblers are
easier to take down by headshots since
they are slower and also large both with
lesser armor outgrowths near the head
explosives are still the best way to
take them down especially if there are
many of them in one place but fire is
also the best way to kill a shambler as
they are highly inflammable this can be
done by shooting a flaming arrow at them
or just by using a small mulch of
cocktail shamblers are tough and can
cause significant damage with their
explosive attacks so the best way is a
quick attack with fire and explosives
like a hit and run
and lastly the Rat King the Rat King is
an Abomination composed of stalkers
clickers and bloaters connected together
by the cordyceps fungus as the most
powerful infected known the Rat King can
endure tremendous amounts of damage and
effortlessly demolish whole building
floors and walls just by walking through
them it appears to have developed as a
result of being trapped in a room so
tightly filled with spores that as the
fungal growth Blossom a number of the
infected are fused together there is no
easy way to kill this Beast even massive
amounts of fire and explosive will only
cause it to split into a bloater and a
stalker which can then be killed by even
more explosives and Strikes to the Head
respectively
so those are the various ways to kill
the different forms of infected in the
last of us so I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit that like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam